c'est un mec qui est persuadé que sa
femme le trompe il décide de rentrer à
l'improviste c'est-à-dire il rentre à
13h ouvre la porte en furie trouve sa
femme dans le couloir à poil et lui dit
il est où il est où cet il ouvre
toutes les armoires tout le bol il
trouve rien et à un moment il se
souvient que Dieu de son 15e étage il a
la chance d'avoir un petit balcon qui se
dirigea porte fenêtre il ouvre et là il
le voit le mec il
est il va dans sa caisse à outils pour
un marteau et lui pète tous les doigts
les uns les autres il lâche il tombe de
15 étages heureusement il y a trois ou
quatre arbres bien serrés en dessous qui
lui amortisse sa chute l'autre en haut
regard
il bouge encore s'enculer il attrape le
frigidaire c'est un monstre le